estas imágenes revelan la devastación
causada por los misiles rusos endesa los
ataques apenas pasada la medianoche
redujeron los apartamentos a cenizas los
rescatistas buscan entre los escombros
intentando encontrar supervivientes
decenas de personas podrían estar
atrapadas entre las ruinas
cuando vine aquí los trabajadores de
emergencia la policía los psicólogos ya
estaban sobre el terreno estaban todos
ocupados ha habido muertos no sé cuántos
pero hay muertos
oímos estruendos vivimos muy cerca
llegamos aquí para valorar la situación
con los servicios de emergencia y otros
vecinos y ayudar a los que sobrevivieron
y a los que desafortunadamente murieron
ayudamos a sacarlos de actos
los ucranianos se levantaron este
viernes con las noticias del ataque y el
parlamento guardó un minuto de silencio
por las víctimas los misiles impactaron
a menos de 100 kilómetros de odessa el
mayor puerto ucraniano en el mar negro
hasta ahora o de esa no había sido tan
impactada por los combates como otros
puntos del país pero en los últimos días
rusia ha intensificado los ataques
aéreos sobre la ciudad y sus alrededores
moscú también tiene bloqueado el puerto
de odessa deteniendo las exportaciones
de grano hacia el resto del mundo y
amenazando con desatar una hambruna
global